On my recent swab testing you added clear GI to my supplements, but on the
store it says those with cancer should not take that product. This product, yes,
I wrote that. Just curious why it is for me because we have to fuel your
your your gastrointestinal tract. So this is the best gut healing product on the
market with the least amount of glutamate. That's why we privately labeled it. And we
been using that product for gosh 15 years. Great product. I don't just I don't give
it to cancer patients. Willie Gilly. Very few people I recommend it for a
tested well on you for your gut. It's not going to be something you're going to be
on for a long term. Has a low enough glutamide that I'm not concerned about it
right now. And it just got so many other really good gut healing nutrients in
there. So also, how do I know when my gut is healed? Well, we don't know when
your gut is healed. You we're just going to we're just going to have to have another
communication and meet a moment of a month. You have to give yourself a month to
six weeks. And the truth is is that how do I know when my gut is healed? Your gut is
never healed. It's constantly breaking down and being damaged by what's the number
one thing that damages your gut. Well, pesticides, GMO foods, glyphosate, food
sensitive needs. And if you're eating foods that you have antibodies to let's say
of antibodies to gluten, then you're eating gluten. Every time you eat gluten,
you're causing an inflammatory process in your gut and your brain and your skin
and elsewhere your lungs and you're just there's no way you can heal it. So you have to look at
food antibodies. That's the benefit of doing the Syrex 3x4 Ray10 test. Ray10 tests 100 different foods
different ones cooked in raw. And it tells you if you have food antibodies, antibodies, two different
foods that you need to lay off of for a period of time. It tells you really, you know, if your
gut is an issue, you know, so that we that we need to work on. So there's other reasons why I'm
personally going to have problems. But certainly the gut wall is one of them. So getting that tested. So
that's why we want you to eat organic. That's why we want you to stay away from GMO foods. That's why
you, you know, don't want to be on, you know, you want to try to avoid medication that's going to
damage your gut as best you possibly can. Well, sometimes there's no way to get in around those things.
And even if you eat perfect and do everything perfect, you're still going to be exposed to
different chemicals, different toxins, different cross-reacted things, pesticides that are in
organic foods, even that are going to damage your gut. So whatever completely healed, it's always a
process. So that's a thing to remember. So we'll check back. And so you can you when you add food,
when you do the array 10, let's say on the Syrex array 10. And you have yellow things and things
in the yellow things in the red. That means it's their positive. I mean, you have antibodies to that
food. And you stay off for a period of time and you start adding things back that are in the yellow
range and you're watching for any reaction in your body. That's one way to do it. You're slowly
adding things back. Another way to do it is to recheck and do another test. So that's another way to check
those things. And the truth is we could take a thousand people off the street and run the Syrex array 10
on them. And I would bet that almost a thousand would have some issues. That's how prevalent this has
become in our society because especially in America, you know, you go over to Europe, you know,
because of the bad cow disease, giant scare that people died of in the 80s, literally everything is
organic over there. You know, there's nothing that is no all GMOs and everything are banned. So
but America allows these things, you know, and we're suffering because of it. The rate of
autoimmune disease is going through the roof. And it's it's just has gotten to the point where
it's not boy, I hope I don't get it in autoimmune disease. It's a wonder which one I'm going to get
because you know, because of our environment, it's a way to be Debbie Downer, but just about
everybody's going to have an autoimmune disease in the United States. So that's why I wrote that
course on the chronic disease in autoimmune. And that's why I think it would be valuable for
even though we are dealing with cancer, you know, if you're not in a crisis mode with cancer,
it'd be good to start going through some of that information.